so Game of Thrones Season eight episode
two is upon us and now Game of Thrones
season 8 episode two I will talk about
air and once again this episode is
brought to you by Stardust the Stardust
app of course it's a social media app
that lets you react to movies trailers
TV shows you get to be the reviewer and
get your opinions out there for 30
seconds at a time I'm starters I'll put
a link below to the Stardust app follow
me at Jeremy Jones and also tag me at
that same handle on the Stardust app and
your Game of Thrones episode reactions
going forward and that'll enter you for
a chance to win a trip for you and a
friend to go to Los Angeles for the Game
of Thrones series finale party that the
folks Stardust are putting on and I'll
be at that party too I'll talk a little
more about that at the end of the
episode but for now let's talk about
Game of Thrones season 8 episode 2 and
of course there are spoilers in here if
you haven't seen it yet but you might
not want to watch this if you don't care
hey watch this but really my big
takeaway from all of this is Tyrion
Lannister once again he stuck the
landing he gave me another phrase that I
want on the tombstone I feel like my
tombstone is gonna be filled up with
Tyrion Lannister phrases but is phrasing
here - the perils of self-betterment cuz
it also shows what Game of Thrones is
really about it really is about self
betterment and characters overcoming
their flaws and we see that with Jaime
Lannister Jaime Lancers so easy to
remember that Jaime Lannister pushed
bran stark out of the windows of the
tower and he fell and snapped his spine
but as he was standing there among the
courts Odin Aerys I was like oh yeah he
stabbed her dad in the back that's why
he's the Kingslayer he stabbed the Mad
King her father and she knows that
yeah bran doesn't care about the tower
thing figured he wouldn't put Daenerys
she's holding a grudge she's a Targaryen
after all they're known for grudges and
fire and Dragons and conquering but she
rolls with this she rolls with it
because really a lot of people in that
room had his back they're all like nah
Daenerys he's totally cool he helped me
there he helped them there and your dad
was a dick he had a pretty great reason
for stabbing your dad in the back that
was gonna burn people like burn him
alive [ __ ] him but she rolls with Jaime
Lannister just like we're all with Jaime
Lannister like we saw him push bran out
the window we saw him when he was a dick
we've also seen him become better and
now we're totally cool with it we're
like on his side like dude Daenerys come
on let's cut him a break he's awesome
now like eight years ago Jaime Lannister
pushed a kid out of a window but yeah
well we forgive him he's cool now seven
years ago Theon Greyjoy sacks Winterfell
conquers it people die
yeah will we forgive him now you can go
ahead and guard bran Stark it's cool we
strictly conflicts with our roles like
our role does like you made a [ __ ] up
joke on Twitter eight years ago
oh [ __ ] you and the career you wrote in
on man we're burning you to the ground
so Westeros may seem unforgiving but in
terms of ruthlessness it's like Westeros
Twitter but Daenerys in sounds I have
this dialogue with each other about
manipulation and she's like well who
manipulated who because I love Jon Snow
it's like everyone manipulates everyone
come on that's right Daenerys you're
manipulating her right now because you
need to because you want the throne
she's thrown hungry-man she's like
thrown drunk that's my point there
everyone in Game of Thrones who wants a
position of power or is in a position of
power they're all manipulative to
everybody tell everyone where it serves
them don't act all innocent Daenerys
Arya and gender mm-hmm it happens I was
like oh I read the tastes of sideboob I
just didn't expect it I just may because
I've known arias and she was little I
mean I've seen Arya kill people slice
throats but sex who Joseph ass-backwards
we are as a society about Kendriya I
ship it for one night only she doesn't
seem like the type it gets tied down
with I'm glad lady Brienne got knighted
she's been like one of the best
characters since her introduction she's
in fact so awesome that in Star Wars
they were like hey she's gonna be phasma
and you never see her face it's like
that cast Gwendoline Christie and never
used Gwendoline Christie it's kind of
weird but Game of Thrones uses
Gwendoline Christie she beat up the
Hound and now she's knighted and now
it's all good Jaime Lannister just wants
to serve under her I run actually that's
a good moment the guy who wants to serve
under her had the ability to Knight her
and he did she was instrumental in Jaime
Lannister's Redemption redeeming himself
because he did things that are not
nearly as offensive as cracking bad
jokes on Twitter I've always liked the
dynamic between Brienne and Jaime
Lannister they have been my favorite
anyway so I'm glad the pair is still
here the duo is alive [ __ ] I hope it in
jinx it hope one of them doesn't die
next week and now Daenerys knows about
Jon Snow's lineage she knows she knows
that he is a relative a blood relative
and the male heir to the Iron Throne I
guess she took it about as well as I
figured she would which is pretty much
like wait a mem she has thrown drunk she
loves that throne she wants it more than
anything and me thanks kid anybody she's
not here for Jon Snow she's in the north
take out the zombies so when she takes
the throne she doesn't have that kind of
opposition I'm telling me in the game of
Thrones there are no friends just
temporary alliances I'm not talking
about the friend friends no Jon Snow
Sam Tarly are actually friends is Sam
Tarly doesn't want the throne now but
when you have one or more people who is
going for the throne now their friends
are not necessarily friend friends now
interestingly enough in this episode
there's a lot of talking I mean I like
the character building I like seeing
where the characters are their headspace
he had a couple of good moments with
Terry in with the Hound with Arya the
Hound the guy who was [ __ ] brought
back to life from the Lord of Light but
I feel like the first episode last
week's episode was a lot of people
talking in Winterfell this episode was a
lot of people talking in Winterfell well
that's to your six episodes next week I
believe is gonna be the battle and was
it goes to King's Landing and then the
week after that is when we go back to
Winterfell and then we see the fight I
just hope they don't spend too much time
building up to what needs to happen
because now we have four more episodes
and we have to have a fight with the
White Walkers and the mythical zombies
of the north and then probably fight
Cersei unless I don't know Arya Stark
sneaks in there and stabs her in the
neck which I guess she could just do
that and then the wrap-up or is one
episode gonna be devoted to them
traveling is it just gonna keep on the
people in the north are we gonna see
what's happening in King's Landing is
there's I feel like there's more that
needs to happen than there are episodes
that can show it I just don't want the
show to feel rushed this is this is the
last is the final season of a show that
a lot of us have man it's bet we've been
there for it haven't felt like I wanted
a show to stick the landing this much
since Breaking Bad and Breaking Bad did
it I don't want this one to fall short
and be like we'll see what happens I
think that's my takeaway so like I said
before this is brought to you by
Stardust click the link below download
the Stardust a follow me at Jeremy Jones
on the Stardust at on Sunday after you
watch new Game of Thrones episodes react
to those Game of Thrones episodes and
tag me at Jeremy Jones in those
reactions and not only will that give
you a chance to be featured here in my
Game of Thrones episodes that I'm doing
here on YouTube that'll also enter you
for a chance to win a trip for you and a
guest to go to Los Angeles for the Game
of Thrones series finale party that the
folks at Stardust are putting on yeah
I'll be at that party I'll be washing in
the Game of Thrones series finale at
that party I'll be a [ __ ] party
watching it laughing crying talking [ __ ]
so do that because it'll be fun
speaking of Stardust reactions that'll
be featured here here are some Stardust
reactions for Game of Thrones season 8
episode 2 I still adore it very much
because think about it
this is gonna be the last peaceful
moment we have with these characters
next week the shit's gonna hit the fan
all hell is gonna break loose
John tells her like y'all make our
garyun I'm your nephew we've been
banging nope I still care about the and
I especially love Jamie in this episode
because he's just kind to everybody and
he's honest to everybody brands little
comment about them maybe not even making
it isn't very reassuring but we did get
a lot of good stuff Ari and Gendry yes I
like this episode a lot I think this was
a really good episode we got a lot of
emotional things between people like
Jaime and Brienne and I love be online
like I try to take the castle from you
now I'm going to fin you the question I
have is who makes this out alive
everyone's gonna die in the next episode
and no one will be safe not even John
and Danny for the night has come holy
[ __ ] last guy [ __ ] got real I don't know
dark mindset it's [ __ ] Westeros who
knows those are just snippets of
reactions but that you know it used but
I can't I wanted use more people but
thank you for everyone who reacted the
Game of Thrones thank you for tagging me
in it alright so now you know my
thoughts you know their thoughts so Game
of Thrones season 8 episode 2 have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you
[Music]